So, I think we're on August the 8th, 1906, is that right?
Yes, sure.
Okay, so how is this necessary to run without ever stopping?
It sounds funny kind of thing.
But beside it put Philippians 3, 14 to 16, Paul says, "I run the race and I'm going
to run it to the finish, I'm not going to stop."
And what Jesus wants from us is that it's all very well to start living in the divine
will and to start doing acts in the divine will, quite another matter altogether to persevere.
Okay.
So, this morning blessed Jesus came for just a little and since I was all tired because
of his privation, he told me, "My daughter, in order for the soul to reach her central
point, it's necessary that she run always without ever stopping because by running, watch this
now.
Number one, her path will become smoother and as she keeps going, number two, the point
which she must reach in order to find the center will be manifested to her.
And number three, along the way, the grace which is necessary for her journey will be
administered to her and it will be administered in such a way that helped by grace she will
not feel the weight of her toiling or of her life.
In other words, the journey that we have in the divine will to substitute for everybody
and make reparation for everyone is a long one.
If you consider just the sheer numbers that are on the earth today, the seven point something
billion and then all of them in the past and all of them in the future, it's a long journey
to substitute for them all.
And we might think that one little act in the divine will is magic, but it's only one
thread in a garment, do you know what I mean?
That's not the garment.
So all the part, all the opposite for one who walks and stops, in fact, just by stopping,
she will feel the tiredness of those steps which is already taken and will lose stamina
for the journey.
Now this is volume seven.
I want to jump you to about volume 15 for a second where Louisa is deep into divine will
at that particular point and Jesus tells her that if she stops in his dimension, it has
the same value as you stopping the sun, that we don't have any idea what we're actually
doing in our divine will acts.
We have no idea of the enormity of what is actually happening.
But you see, he will only give you a piece of information slowly so that you can take
them on board, we're too early in volume seven to take such a gigantic thing on board.
We need an awful lot more instruction, okay.
So here you just get the tiredness, we're on August 8, 1906.
By not walking, she will not be able to see her point, which is a good most high and will
not be attracted to it.
Not seeing her run, grace will not give itself in vain.
I think that needs to be underlined for 110 reasons.
Grace won't give itself in vain because you know from volume one that grace is God himself
poured out upon us, okay.
So he won't give himself in vain and her life will become unbearable because idleness
produces boredom and bother.
Now this is being addressed to Louisa who's in a bed, okay, and if she is not actually
accomplishing her mission, of course the very first thing you'd get in sitting in a bed
is boredom isn't it, to the point of tedium.
She does mention that a few times as you go along that she suffered from tedium.
Sometimes an awful thing as you know, as you know one of the early things you hear from
a young child is I'm bored, you know, they can't take five minutes of not being occupied,
okay.
So August 10, 1906, I have a VIP on this one.
One contentment less on the earth, one paradise more in heaven.
You see we just don't really grasp the fullness of what's being said to us, okay.
Continue in my usual state.
I saw blessed Jesus for just a little and he told me, my daughter, for every slightest
pleasure of which the soul deprives herself in this life for love of me, notice the for
love of me, not for any other reason, I will give her one more paradise in the next life.
Now you see, what we can't grasp is the message one more paradise, because we think there's
only one, but he's talking about different levels of happiness and different types of
happiness and the happiness is what we call paradise.
So one contentment less here, one paradise more there.
Imagine a bit how many privations you have suffered in these 20 years of bed.
So where we are now, she's been 20 years sitting in that bed.
No wonder you talk about boredom, okay.
And how many more paradises I will give you in heaven, okay.
Now, the next few lines is a big surprise.
And all I've written in my book is surprise.
On hearing this, Louisa said, my good, what are you saying?
I feel honoured and almost your debtor because you give me the occasion to be deprived for
love of you, huh?
You've heard her complaining about it for six volumes and all of a sudden she realises
that it is actually a privilege, okay.
I've often said to parents, will you stop complaining about your privileges when they're
talking about their children?
Because sometimes they complain about the problems and all the rest, they stop complaining
about your privileges.
You have the privilege of having a child, okay.
So she said, I feel almost your debtor because you give me the occasion to be deprived for
love of you.
That's the essence of the thing.
And you tell me that you give me many paradises, and yeah, it is precisely so.
So naturally she writes to you guys, yes, after that, okay.
So that's the first time Louisa really gets 10 out of 10 for her response, okay.
So August the 11th, 1906, the cross is a treasure.
Now we know this theoretically, we just don't want to know it practically.
So finding myself in my usual state, I saw my adorable Jesus with a cross in his hand,
all full of white pearls.
Seeing it to me as a gift, he placed it on my breast and it sank into my heart as inside
a room.
In other words, this is where this furniture goes.
Then he told me, my daughter, the cross is a treasure.
And the safest place in which to keep this valuable treasure is in one's own soul.
Or rather, it is a safe place when the soul is disposed to receive the treasure with patience
and resignation, both of which are absolutely essential when the cross comes to you.
And with the other virtues, because the virtues are as many keys to secure it.
Now if you're going through a difficult time, and it's really costing you, that's what we
call the cross, then you'll discover what patience is and long suffering and kindness
and humility and all the other vert, they all have to kick in, everyone, he calls them
the keys.
And he says the golden key is patience, that one really needs to be underlined.
At some stage when we get to a deeper level of studying these volumes, and we're going
to pick out different words, and one of them is the golden key, he gives you quite a number
of keys.
The golden key is patience, this treasure will find many thieves who will steal and spoil
it.
Now August the 25th, 1906 is a warning about priests.
This morning, finding myself outside of myself, I seemed to see priests and prelates intent
on there, we would say personal interest, you need to put the word personal in there.
And on human sciences, which are not necessary for their state, now the human sciences are
not the theological sciences, so they're not theology and scripture and everything to
do with scripture, it's to do with the fact they've gone into other sciences, and I feature
their running schools and colleges and everything, teaching everything, you know.
That's what he's talking about, he said it's not necessary for their state.
With the addition of a spirit of rebellion against the authorities superior to them.
So the spirit of rebellion can be against the people immediately above them, that would
be the bishops, or if they're in communities, the superiors of the communities, and the
top one is the pope, and we've had all kinds of problems.
All afflicted our Lord told me, my daughter, personal interest is what you'd have to put
there, human sciences, and everything that does not pertain to the priest forms a second
nature for him, muddy and rotten.
Muddy meaning brings him into sin, you know, that mud is always associated with sin in
these writings.
And rotten, of course, means that it is only for this earth and it's not good for you anyway.
So muddy and rotten is going to destroy him as a priest, okay?
And the works that come out of him, even holy, are so stinking that I feel nausea and they're
unbearable to me.
That's quite a statement.
Pray and repair for these offenses for I can take no more.
He says quite a lot about how the priesthood can go wrong in these writings, okay?
And the answer, of course, is not to fight them, but to make reparation and substitute
for them, so that grace can come back.
So September the 2nd, 1906, I have a VIP on this one as well.
Louisa wants to do the accounts with Jesus and Jesus wants her to have no thought about
herself.
And doing the accounts means getting ready for debt and trying to sort out that you're
in the black and not in the red before you die, okay?
That's the doing of the account.
This morning, having to receive communion, I was prepared to make a day of retreat.
That is, to prepare myself for debt.
Now, most of us don't consider a day of retreat, a day of preparing yourself for debt.
And after I received communion, I said to bless Jesus, let's do the account now, in
other words, before the judgment, okay?
So I was not to leave them for the last extreme of my life.
I myself don't know how I am.
I make no reflection over myself.
Really, Louisa is saying something which would be really frowned at at the time.
And that is, you know, if you're not doing your daily examine of conscience or something
wrong with you.
So I make no reflection over myself, she said.
And by not reflecting on it, I do not perceive myself.
And so I feel neither fears, nor scruples, nor agitations.
Imagine facing death, feeling neither fear, scruples, nor agitation.
That means everything's fine.
And while I see that others who are far more good than I am, and even the very lives of
the saints which I have read, and they all reflect upon themselves, that is something
that the Lord doesn't want when you're in divine will.
You're only to think of Him, and what you can do to repair, and to save souls for Him,
and you have to think of others.
He'll think of you.
Okay.
In other words, divine will spirituality is not a beginner's spirituality, hence the
examination of conscience is very important if you're under beginner's spirituality.
Is that okay?
Because you're still fighting sin.
But if you're in divine will, and you're not fighting sin, because you can't be in the
divine will and have sinned, sin, therefore the issues are completely different, okay?
So they all reflect about themselves, whether they're cold or warm, that is spiritually.
Whether tempted or calm, that is spiritually as well, whether they confess well or badly.
Now, they confess well or badly.
This is 1906, and one of the things that was going on in the church at the time was that
people thought that screw velocity was somehow holy.
Even St. Therese of Lyseus suffered from screw velocity until the Lord released her from it.
But the Lord will condemn screw velocity absolutely because it's too much reflection
on me.
How did I feel?
How did I not feel?
How did I do?
How did I not do?
That's all concentrated on the self.
So here's the screw velocity about whether I confessed well or didn't, okay?
And she said, and almost all of them are shy, agitated and scrupulous.
Well, that's the exact opposite what you have in divine will, where the peace goes deeper
and deeper and deeper, okay?
All my attention instead is on wanting you, unloving you and not offending you.
Now, this divine will spirituality is completely on the Lord.
It's a he and I relationship.
As for the rest, I take nothing into account.
It seems I've no time to think of anything else.
And if I engage in doing it, an interior voice shakes me, scolds me and says, "Do you
want to waste time?"
Why is it wasting time?
Because she's gone way beyond that place.
Like if you and I try to squeeze ourselves into the little chairs in the first classes
in the primary school, wouldn't he be wasting time?
As well as putting your back in danger as well.
Think of doing your things with God.
Now, somebody at a very early stage in spirituality is not doing anything with God.
We're doing everything with him, because it's in the divine will, isn't it?
We're doing everything with him.
Therefore I myself do not know the station which I am, whether I'm cold, dry or warm.
And if anyone wanted an account of it, I certainly would not be able to do it.
I think I did it wrong.
So let us do the account now so that I may remedy it.
Now, his answer to this is going to be brilliant, okay?
And before we even give you the next paragraph, I want to give you Matthew 18 verses 1 to 3
at the heading of the next paragraph.
That's where Jesus took a little child and said, "Become like him or her."
Is that okay?
Matthew 18 verses 1 to 3.
It's about the child.
And after I prayed him over and over again, he said to me, "My daughter, I keep you always
on my knees."
And so tightly as to give you no time to think about yourself.
I hold you like a father holds his little child on his knees.
He gives him a kiss now and then he gives him a caress and then he feeds him with his
own hands.
Again, the now, now thing is not English, okay?
If inadvertently the little child gets dirty, the father himself takes care of cleaning him.
That's the normal way of looking after a child, isn't it?
So a weaned child on its mother's lap is Sam 131.
I've given it here many times in these writings because it represents the relationship of a
person in divine will.
A weaned child on its mother's lap.
That child is not thinking about itself, is not worrying about food, is not worrying
about, did I talk to my mother correctly or not correctly or whatever?
That child is totally resting in the joy of that relationship, okay?
And that's the way it is in divine will.
So if the father shows himself afflicted, the little one consoles him and dries his tears.
And if he shows himself irritated, the little one calms him.
In some, the father is the life of the little one, John 14, 6.
I am the way, the truth and the life.
And does not let him have the slightest thought about himself, whether he needs to eat, whether
he gets dirty, whether he needs to clothe himself and not even whether he needs to sleep because
forming a cradle with his arms, he rocks him to make him fall asleep and lets him sleep
on his lap.
Now that sleep is the deep sleep of contemplation, okay?
Because in contemplation you are not available to anybody else, you're only available to God.
And the little one is all relief and the life of the father, while the other grown up children
take care of reordering the house and cleaning themselves by themselves and all the rest
of it.
So they're in a different relationship.
This is how I work with you.
I keep you on my knees like a little dover and so intimately united with me as to not
let you feel yourself.
Now, would you underline that?
What do you mean by not letting you feel yourself?
In later volumes when Louisa gets herself into a momentary crisis, she says, "But I can
feel myself, this is terrible."
She is living in such an ecstatic relationship with the Lord.
She's only conscious of him and she's conscious of whether she takes the cross or sufferings
from him or whether she's being deprived of him.
She's not conscious of all the petty needs of her own emotions.
She's not conscious of that at all.
She's living in an absolutely extraordinary relationship.
She's detached from her salary?
Oh no, it's much more.
Yeah, even for her.
Oh, it's much more.
She's not even conscious of it.
Everybody is conscious of how they feel and whether they're feeling well or sick or cold
or whatever.
She's not.
She's living in such an extraordinary communication with the Lord, but she'd have to be there
for the amount of visitation she's getting.
Okay.
And that's why he says, "Not letting you feel yourself."
So she's not aware of bodily needs.
That's not extraordinary.
It is if you think about it.
I think can take care of all of you, cleaning you if you're stained, feeding you if you
need food.
In some, I anticipate you in everything.
In such a way that you yourself do not perceive your needs.
And by holding you intimately tight to me, it is a grace that I give you because you
escape many, many defects.
This is when we're conscious of ourselves and what I want in all the rest, lots of defects
come with it.
While if you had thought of yourself, "Oh, how many defects you would fall into," therefore
think only of doing your office of little daughter of the divine will towards me and
have no thought for anything else.
So she was correct in saying, "This is the condition I'm in.
I don't think of anything except loving him."
But what an exalted relationship she has.
And compare that with the people she describes in the first paragraph, who have fears and
scruples and agitations and don't even know whether they confessed properly or whether
they didn't.
So it's all centered around the self.
Now in divine will, you have to push the self completely aside, get into your nothingness
so that he can act in a sovereign way in your life and that you stay in your nothingness
so that he can continue there.
That's where we're going in the divine will.
It's the most wonderful place to be.
I think the nothingness is brilliant.
I keep telling the Lord, this is one of the most brilliant things he ever told us because
if you get into that nothingness, you're not looking at whether I succeeded or didn't
succeed or whether I failed or didn't fail.
You're only looking at giving him the opportunity to be creator and Lord and master and absolutely
everything to us.
It's brilliant.
It's total freedom.
And by comparing it to all these scruples and stuff, the different world.
Okay, so September the 11th, 1906, everything which is not done for the glory of God remains
obscured.
Now these messages are for people living in the divine will, you do not judge people
who don't know about the divine will.
Is that okay?
I have to say that frequently to people.
As I was in my usual state, I found myself with baby Jesus in my arms in the midst of
many people.
And he said to me, my daughter, all the works, all the words, all the thoughts of people
should be sealed with the mark, the glory of God, the glory of God.
It's glory and day, okay?
And everything which is not sealed with this mark remains obscured and as though buried
in darkness stained or at most is of literally no value, isn't that incredible?
So when you move into the divine will, you've moved away from all that other spirituality
that prepared for it.
And here in the divine will, if everything is not for the glory of God, it's a total
waste of time.
And if it's not done out of love for God, it's a waste of time as well.
So we need to sort of do a little check on ourselves every now and then.
So the person does nothing other than pull out darkness and abominable things from herself
because by not operating for the glory of God, the soul runs away from the purpose for
which she was created.
She is as though lost from God and left alone with herself.
Think of a child lost from its parents.
God alone is light, one John, one five, one John, one five.
And it is through God that human actions acquire value.
Now what is the wonder if the soul by not operating for his glory remains buried in our
own darkness and gains nothing from her toils on the country.
She loads herself with heavy debts.
Now the debts are all the defects that you accumulate from doing things wrongly and
all the time you've wasted and all the rest of it.
To our great bitterness, we looked at all those people as though buried in darkness.
In order to distract blessed Jesus from that bitterness, I would clasp him and kiss him
and almost wanting to play with him, I would say to him, I would add a few words, I want
you to say with me and here's Louis dictating a prayer to Jesus.
I find that unbelievable, I don't know about you.
And she's ordering him to say, I give such power to the prayer of this soul as to concede
what she asks of me.
Do you think he's going to resist it?
Well he wouldn't listen to me and I wanting to force him to say it with me would renew
the kisses, look at the blandish ones, okay?
The embraces and I would repeat it, say it together with me and the same words.
And she said, I did so much that it seemed that he actually said it.
In other words, I pestered him so much, I'll be side that I want you to put Matthew 1112.
The Kingdom of God suffers violence and the violent taken by force.
She really pestered him to say it.
The other one I want to give you is Matthew 18 verses 1 to 8.
Do you remember the woman and the unjust judge?
She got it out of him by simply pestering him, okay.
Now Louisa does that, what did she ask Jesus to say?
I give such power to the prayer of this soul as to concede what she asks of me.
I mean she has to be in an absolutely astonishing relationship with the Lord for him, for her
to even think of asking him to say that.
Because she's acknowledging that she has a very high place with him, okay.
Then she said, it seems he said it, she said, I have to do with the serpent.
Then I found myself in South, inside of myself she's back out of the ecstasy, surprised
at my daringness and madness and I feel ashamed of myself.
That's a bit more normal, isn't it?
So September 12, 1906, where God is not present there can be neither firmness nor true good.
Now what is called firmness in these writings we would call stability and perseverance, okay.
So I think you need to put the other words with it as well.
So stability and perseverance, okay.
So if God is not present you won't get the perseverance and the stability.
So I want you to put one John two six with that, one John two six.
I was thinking about my state, Louisa says, which now seems to be all peace and love.
Nothing disturbs me, everything is good, nothing is sin.
And I said to myself, what will happen if at the moment of my death the scene will change
or she hasn't given up on the death thing.
One of the things I love about this woman is she doesn't give up easily.
If she's pursuing something, she will pursue it.
And sometimes Jesus has to say, are you going to go on, aren't you ever going to stop?
He does say that to her a few times.
So here she's back to her death thing now.
He hasn't answered it the way she wants.
So what will happen if at the moment of my death the scene will change and I will see
the reverse of this that is all things will disturb me and everything I have done will
be a chain of evils.
Has she taken on board what she has just heard or no?
Are we like that as well?
How often do we have to hear something before it registers?
While I was thinking of this, he told me, my daughter, it seems you want to disturb
yourself and you want to do it by force and you want to take away from me my continuous
rest in you.
I want to give you a few scriptures for that.
2 Corinthians 6, 16, 2 Corinthians 6, 16, 1 John 4, 13, and Ephesians 3, 17, have you
got that?
2 Corinthians 6, 16, 1 John 4, 13, and Ephesians 3, 17.
Do you think that your patience, the constancy, now there's another word, you see the firmness,
put the word constancy with it as well.
The constancy and the peace of this state of yours is your own or rather that it's the
fruit of the grace of the one who dwells in you.
I alone possess these gifts and from the constancy, the peace, and the patience that you can
recognize who it is that operates in you.
It's not you, it's the Lord.
John 15, 5, without him, without me, he says you can do nothing, am I right?
Okay.
So if you have these things that you can recognize inside of you, then he says you realize it
is me that's doing it, okay.
In fact, when it is her own nature, you need to add in the little word OWM to make sense
in English.
When it's her own nature or the devil, the soul feels dominated by continuous changes.
That's very interesting.
Now notice these changes are the exact opposite of the constancy, stability, firmness, peace.
You see that, and we have one of these sentences with now, now, now, I knocked them all out.
She feels one mood and then another.
First she's all patience and then she's all vexation.
So notice the contrasts as you show her sign that it's not grace, okay.
In sum, the poor one is flapped about like a reed blowing in the strong wind, Luke 714.
Where Jesus said that about John the Baptist, he was not a reed blowing in the wind, do you
remember?
Luke 724.
Did I say 14?
It's Luke 724.
Am I daughter?
Where God is not present, there can be neither firmness, stability, constancy, now they have
all these words, nor true good, therefore do not want to disturb my rest and yours.
What is his rest and hers, haven't we just read about it, that she's sitting on the lap
like a child in his father's arms, that's the rest, okay.
And he says, "Rather, be more grateful," oops.
He keeps on identifying the human race as ungrateful.
So I want to give you a whole lot of scriptures that you have to be grateful to God.
Okay, Isaiah 38 verses 18 to 19.
The Psalms are full of it, but in the Psalms, it's called Thanksgiving, okay.
Psalm 107 verses 8, 15, 21, and 31.
And then just put it, etc., there's loads of Psalms, okay.
I want to give you Luke 17, 16, the leper who was healed, came back and threw himself at
the feet of Jesus in Thanksgiving, Romans 1.8, Acts 24.3, Colossians 1.3 and 3.15.
This is to give you a flavor because he goes on and on and on so much about being grateful
that I decided to look up a whole letter of references for you today, I looked them up.
So September the 14th, 1906, Jesus defends the soul who gives herself completely to him.
The place of souls in the humanity of Jesus is rather interesting.
This morning I was outside of myself and I saw baby Jesus within a mirror.
I don't know how you manage that one, so very clear and large such that I could see him very
well from any point in which I would place myself.
So it's like the whole of mirrors, you know.
I made a sign with my hand for him to come to me and Jesus made a sign that I should
go to him.
That's playing, isn't it?
In the meantime, I saw many devout people and priests.
Now what she calls devout people may or may not be lay people, it may be religious, okay?
It may or may not.
And priests as though placing themselves between me and him, so she has called him, he has
called her and they want to block, okay?
And they were talking about me.
I would not pay attention to them, my aim was my sweet Jesus, however.
He came out from within that mirror all in a hurry and wanted to beat those who were
talking, saying to them, nobody touched her because when one touches one who loves me,
I feel more offended than they were touching me directly.
Isn't that very interesting?
There was a scripture I was tempted to put in there, but I'm only going to say it and
not give you the reference so you won't write it down, that way, okay.
Much not my anointed says the Lord.
And to my prophets you do know harm.
That's a very clear prohibition in the Old Testament.
That's not my anointed, and to my prophets do know harm.
I didn't want to write it down in case I was stretching the text a bit, okay.
But I think it fits the know about you.
Here he is defending her because Louisa has given herself completely to him, noticed the
others with their gas bagging and their gossiping are not exactly pleasing to the Lord, okay.
I will show you how I know how to take the part of the one who gives herself completely
to me and of her innocence, so obviously in the gossip they're accusing, aren't they?
And he clashed me with one arm while threatening them with the other one, isn't that interesting?
The image there is of a parent defending the child against other people, okay.
So I want to give you Matthew 7, 1 to 10 where you're told not to criticize, not to judge
and so on.
That's Matthew 7, 1 to 10.
I did not care at all about what they would speak, that they would speak ill of me, that's
why I gave you the Matthew 7 thing.
I was only sorry that he wanted to beat them and I said to him, "My sweet life, I do not
want anyone to suffer because of me and from this I will know whether you love me if you
can yourself with them and you don't beat them."
Telling the Lord what to do again, notice that, "otherwise I will be discontent."
So it seemed that he calmed himself and he pulled me away from the midst of these people
taking me into himself, very interesting, isn't it?
As I would continue to see him no longer as a child, this time crucified, I said to him,
"My adorable good, since when you suffered the crucifixion, all souls had a place in
your humanity, what was my place?"
It's very interesting.
Don't you ever ask the Lord that, "What was your place, have you?"
And Terese said, "I will be love in the heart of the church."
She knew her place was in the heart of Jesus, her whole thing was love, that's what Jesus
says here as well.
My daughter, the place of the loving souls was in my heart.
As for you then, in addition to keeping you in my heart, since you were to cooperate in
redemption with your state of victim soul, I keep you in all of my members as help and
relief.
Now, all of my members is the body of Christ, isn't it?
Galatians 6, 17, that's suffering for the body of Christ.
And Philippians 1, 29 to 30, Philippians 1, Philippians 1, 29 to 30, 29 to 30.
Okay.
So, September the 16th, 1906, it's very interesting, Louisa is having visitors.
And she says, "I don't know what to say to these people, I have no idea how to impress
them or anything else."
And of course, you're going to expect him to say, "You don't have to, aren't you?"
Okay, so what is response?
Actually, the heading is good, the sheer truth, naked and simple, is the most powerful magnet
to draw a heart.
It's a very good introduction, that one.
As the confessor told me, that man's senior, now that's the bishop, did not want people
to come and visit me so that I might not be distracted.
Now, don't you think the church is getting interested in this one?
We're on Volume 7, and it's taken the church quite a time to realize that there's something
special going on here.
So if the bishop says that this woman is not to be disturbed by lots and lots of visitors,
it means that they're getting very interested in what's going on, which I think is great.
So, Louisa said to him, "You have given this obedience more than months, but it's never
sorted out, because Louisa can't stop even coming to the house, it has to be other people.
She's stuck in a bed, isn't she?
It's done for a little while, and then things go back as before.
Well, if you give me the obedience not to speak anymore, my silence would drive everybody
away."
So, it's the only solution she can think of.
Now, having received communion, I said to the Lord, "If it pleases you, I would like
to know how things are in your sight.
You know the state of violence in which I find myself when I am with people, because
with you alone I feel comfortable.
That is an extremely important statement.
It tells you everything about Louisa.
Show me your friends, and I'll tell you who you are.
Isn't that correct?
I feel comfortable only with you.
That means you're dealing with an extremely high state of holiness here.
I cannot understand why they want to come.
I show myself rustic, in other words, she doesn't understand where they're coming from.
I use no means to attract them, but rather unpleasant manners.
Why do they come?
I don't know.
Heaven's grant that I may remain alone.
Now, there's the mystic alone with the alone, and alone with the alone is the meaning of
solitude.
Okay?
So, the need for solitude shows this very deep relationship with God.
So, at that moment, Jesus said to Louisa, "My daughter, the sheer truth, naked and simple,
is the most powerful magnet to draw hearts and to dispose them, to face any sacrifice
for love of the truth and of the people who reveal this truth."
Now, for that, I want to give you John 8, 32, John 8, 32, and 40.
Jesus is in controversy with the Pharisees, and he's telling them that only the truth
will set you free.
Do you remember that one?
Okay.
Who disposed the martyrs to shed their blood?
It was the truth.
Who gave to many other saints the strength to conduct a pure and unblemished life in
the midst of many battles?
It was the truth.
So, let me give you John 14, 17, John 14, 17, John 16, 13, John 17, 17, and also verse
17, and John 18, 37.
There's a good bit of John's gospel, isn't it?
And besides that, I want to give you one Corinthians 1, 21 to 23.
It was the truth that enabled all the saints to conduct a pure and unblemished life amidst
so many battles.
There are battles within themselves, you know, to conquer themselves.
The truth and a naked, simple, and disinterested truth, in other words, you don't have to dress
up the Word of God.
You can't improve on the Word of God.
The Word of God is complete.
This is why people want to come to you.
In other words, they're just getting the unblemished truth, which she's not being social or PC with
them.
And my daughter, in these sad times, how hard it is to find people who would manifest this
naked truth, even among the clergy, the religious and the devout people, now you know that the
devout people are laity.
But sometimes in these writings, you're not sure what they're actually saying, okay?
They're speaking and operating always nurses something human.
In other words, there's human rationalization going on, okay, there's human reasons given
for things.
It's not purely what God is saying.
They always nurse something human, something of personal interest and other things, and
the truth is manifested as though covered or veiled.
I want to give you one Corinthians two versus one to five, one Corinthians two versus one
to five.
Now notice that someone teaching can actually damage the truth.
They can put a veil over it by giving you the latest opinions about whatever, whatever,
and the seriousness of preaching God's word is that the preacher or the teacher can actually
destroy it by just replacing it with all kinds of human stuff.
That's going on all around us and has been going on for a very long time.
So the person who receives the word of God is not touched by the naked truth.
Naked means that it's not dressed up.
They're only touched by the interest or the other human purpose in which the truth has
been wrapped, as like saying, you're only interested in the wrapper, not the gift, and
he doesn't receive the grace and the influence which the truth contains.
So if we're only at the outer wrapper of somebody talking and proclaiming themselves, really,
there's no grace.
This is why so many sacraments, so many confessions are wasted, profaned, and without fruit, I'd
put a big envy there, wouldn't you?
Even though I do not abstain from giving them light, it helps them.
But they don't listen to me because they think of themselves that if they do so, they would
lose their prestige and they're being well liked, their nature would no longer find satisfaction
and they would go against their own interests.
Oh, dear heavens, they won't listen to God because they're proclaiming themselves.
That's what it is.
Oh, how they deceive themselves.
In fact, one who leaves everything for love of the truth will super abound in everything
more profusely than others.
Okay.
I want to give you John 544, Jesus in controversy with his writings and Pharisees and he said
to them, "You look to one another for approval and you don't look for God's approval."
He said, "It's all wrong."
He condemned it, absolutely.
So I want to give you Galatians 1, 10 as well.
In fact, one who leaves everything for love of the truth will super abound in everything
more profusely than others.
Therefore, as much as you can, do not let lack to manifest this naked and simple truth.
It is understood, always complying to the obedience of the one who directs you.
In other words, don't go outside of the priest's guidance, but as the opportunity arises, manifest
the truth.
And then she says separately, "All that regards charity," I have said in a veiled manner,
"and since obedience has told me to write everything in detail, I hear the impression
as if I had not obeyed."
As I asked the Lord, he told me that it was fine as it was, because one who finds himself
with those defects would only understand what she had written in a veiled way.
Isn't that sad?
But later, of course, and she has done it in earlier volumes as well, she gives the most
wonderful stuff about charity.
Is that okay?
So September 18, 1906.
Peace is light for the soul, light for her neighbor, and light for God.
After struggling very much, I was feeling all oppressed and almost a little disturbed,
thinking about why my adorable Jesus was not coming.
Then he came in passing, and he told me, "My daughter, peace is light for the soul, light
for her neighbor, and light for God.
Therefore, a soul who is at peace is always light, and being light, she's always united
to the eternal light, one John, one five, the eternal light, which she draws ever new light
so as to be able to give light to others."
You notice everything is light here.
Okay.
So if you want new light, be at peace.
Now I'm going to give you the references for peace.
Not light.
Is that okay?
So Romans 8, 6, and 14, 17.
One Corinthians 7, 15, two Corinthians 1, 2, Galatians 5, 22, Ephesians 2, 14, et cetera.
Because it's all over the New Testament of that peace.
Okay.
Now there's two things there.
They've just been introduced.
They'll be elaborated on in the higher volumes.
One is that we have to go from this heavy weight of human flesh.
We've got to go from that to being pure spirit.
The Lord wants it in this life, okay, and that pure spirit is called light and the language
we usually use is that we are becoming more and more spiritual.
Okay.
Now as you become more and more spiritual, you become in the language you were being told
here, more and more light.
God is light and therefore the mixing of God and the soul becomes easier and easier and
easier.
You become one.
Is that okay?
Light and light mixing.
That's why she's always united to the eternal light.
And going with this is also a level of peace that reaches very quickly a point that St.
Paul says in Philippians 4, 7, which I didn't actually write down, the peace that passes
all understanding and guards your heart and your mind and Christ Jesus.
So there's two more words and it's not too alert you because the list of words that
actually need to be studied by themselves in these writings is colossal, light and peace.
And when you take one of these words and start looking at it from looking at the entire thing
through that word light or through that word peace, you'll get new insights into the whole
thing.
This is showing you where things are going in the future.
So September the 23rd, 1906, how operating for Christ destroys the human work and Jesus
makes rise again into a divine work.
You see, someone not understanding the language of the divine will say that that's all wrong.
How can you destroy a human work, do you know what I mean?
What he's saying is that he shows us how to have our human actions divinized.
That's what he's going to be talking about.
So it's actually a very important message.
This is all about divinizing human actions, okay.
And therefore a very good explanation as to acts in the divine will, okay?
I call this, this is a he and I.
He divinizes me.
As I was in my usual state, blessed Jesus came for a little while and embracing me wholly.
He told me, my beloved, my beloved daughter working for Christ and in Christ makes the
human work disappear completely because by working in Christ, since Christ is fire, he
consumes the human work and after he has consumed the human work, his fire makes rise
again into a divine work.
Before I go any further, Luke 1249, Luke 1249, Hebrews 1229, our God is a consuming fire
and Revelation 2 18.
Now doing it, the church has always told us we do everything through with and in Christ.
Everything is through him with him and in him, okay?
Now that's fine for the old spirituality.
But when you're talking about doing it through him with him and in him here, we're talking
about doing it in the divine will, okay?
So that's where the human aspect of it is pushed aside and the divine aspect is brought
forward because if I say to the Lord, I want to do this in your will, then there's two
wills involved.
I have invited him to take over, haven't I?
Okay.
So if I invite him to take over and I am less than a grain of stand and he is everything,
I'm nothing and he's at all, okay?
Then don't you think that he should take over?
That's what you mean by the human side is pushed aside and the divine side takes over,
okay?
Everyone can do that, we can't do that.
Is that okay?
Yes.
Therefore, operate or work always together with me as if we were both doing the same thing
together.
If you suffer, suffer as if you were suffering together with me, if you pray, if you work,
do everything in me and with me.
In this way, you will lose the human works completely.
In other words, the thing being merely a human thing dies, that's okay?
And you will find them again in the divine.
Oh, how many immense riches people could acquire but they don't avail themselves of
it because they don't understand, you know what I mean?
So I think that's a lovely way of describing how to have the human acts lifted off into
the divine and they become divine acts and the human aspect of it just falls off.
So maybe the thing that's coming to my head, I don't know whether it's the Lord's putting
it there, but he usually does when I'm describing this.
You know, as I'm describing this, he puts images and words and everything into my head.
And the thing that's coming to my head while I was looking at that is the chrysalis that
covers something that needs to be absolutely transformed and then when it falls away,
out comes the butterfly.
And the butterfly lives at a very much higher level than the little creature that produced
it.
There's an absolute transformation of life and a raising of that creature to a much higher
level and that's the image the Lord put into my head, so I'll give it here.
It makes sense after that, doesn't it?
So we enter into him, we're entering into the chrysalis, what we want to do is completely
transformed.
I know we come, the butterfly, we're doing divine acts, isn't it fantastic?
Actually, that idea never crossed my head before.
Okay.
What do you call the creature before it's transformed?
No, the cocoon, what's the caterpillar to the butterfly?
I just want to write down, caterpillar transformed into butterfly because he put it into my head,
so it's obviously right.
Never thought of that before.
Okay, so having said this, he disappeared and I remained with a great desire to see him
again.
Now he's only just disappeared and she can't endure as until he comes back.
It's called being in love, isn't it?
Then I was outside of myself and I kept looking for him everywhere and not finding him, I said,
"Alor, how cruel you are to the soul who is all for you."
He's only just gone.
Now the image I have in my head for that is of a young person in love and the beloved
has just gone home and they ring them before they're down even into the car, you know?
And okay, you are cruel to a soul who is all for you and who does nothing but suffer continuous
deaths for love of you.
See, my will, watch this, is looking for you and not finding you, it dies continuously
because it does not find you who are the life of my will.
Now John 1, 4, he is our life, okay, and John 14, 6, he is our life.
My desires die continuously because as they desire you and do not find you, they do not
find their life.
So my breath, heartbeats of my heart, my memory, my intellect, everything, everything
is undergoing cruel deaths and you have no compassion for me.
Oh dear, at that moment I came back into myself and I found him within me, which she never
satisfied with that, is she?
And as though wanting to give tit for tat, he kept saying, "See, I am all for you, all
in you and all for you."
He seemed to have the crown of thorns, he would push it onto his head and blood would
come out of it and he would repeat, "This blood I am shedding is for love of you."
He would show me his wounds and add, "These, they're all for you."
Oh, how confused I felt seeing that my love compared to his was nothing but his shadow.
This neat lever, he doesn't say to her in words, "I love you."
He says, "You know, I bore the crown of thorns for you."
That's a different matter, isn't it?
So October 2, 1906, how our sufferings can relieve Jesus.
Now you know in these writings that relieving him means saving souls, don't you?
So make sure you write it there on the heading so that you don't miss it in future.
Having received communion, I felt I was outside of myself and I saw a person who was very
oppressed with various crosses and blessed Jesus was saying, "Tell her," that's the
soul, that in the act in which he feels as though dogged by persecutions, by punctures,
punctures of course would refer to the thorns puncturing, okay?
By sufferings, she should think that I am present with her.
Now don't you see, he doesn't say, "Tell her I heal her."
You know, if the Lord wants to heal someone, you know that that's a very early stage in
the spiritual life, do you?
Things are usually to get people started.
Unless we ask the Lord for a miracle as we're doing, for Sean, in order to get Louisa canonized,
we're asking a different subject, but if a person just wants bodily heal, it's a very
early stage.
I hope I'm not scandalizing everybody, am I?
Because people charismatic renewal would send me home immediately, wouldn't they?
Because many of them think that being healed physically is something great.
But this physical thing that we call the body is going to be left behind when I go
off to heaven, and it will be called the remains.
It can't be the most important thing.
And so in the divine will, everything is the healing of the soul, the reordering of your
entire being.
Now some people reach a level of such reordering that the body is completely healed.
Just don't reach that level, or whatever reason, we don't all conquer Mount Everest.
We try smaller hills, you know?
And you've got all this mystery that's going on there.
But it's important that he does not say, "I want to heal this person."
He wants to show this person how to use the cross in a way that it will bring huge benefits
to ourselves and everybody else, it's a much greater thing than just having a painkiller.
What do you think?
It's hard for us to say yes, isn't it?
Because when there's something wrong, we all want it healed.
So when all of this happens, she should think that I am present with her, and that whatever
she suffers, she can use to heal and medicate my wounds.
Okay?
That's a different way now of thinking than we normally have.
So to heal and medicate his wounds, he's talking about the church.
He's in heaven.
He's glorious.
So to heal and medicate his wounds, he's talking about the church and the wounds of
the church.
Therefore, you're offering it in substitution and reparation, okay?
So try putting substitution and reparation there.
So her sufferings will serve to medicate my side, my head and my hands and feet, which
are too much in pain and embittered by the grave offenses that people give me.
This is a great honor that I give her by giving her myself the medicine to medicate my wounds
and by also giving her the merit of charity for having medicated me.
Now the medicine is the cross, okay?
Make sure you put that over it.
The medicine is the cross.
And to medicate his wounds, that's all that's wrong in the church.
We make reparation and substitution for them.
And giving her the merit of charity, that you're doing it for love of God and loving
your neighbor, which is the highest motivation, okay?
So she's gaining an enormous amount.
She's gaining on the whole level of charity and she's gaining on the level of being a
core edeemer, isn't that right?
And she's doing something absolutely huge, and you have to balance that up with someone
who just wants to be healed.
While he was saying this, I saw many purging souls who, on hearing this, were all amazed
and they said, "Fortunate are all of you to receive such sublime teaching."
Now, they know they're on the spiritual side, they're on the side of paradise.
They know they can see the truth.
And they call this sublime teaching, isn't that excellent?
So if it's sublime, put VIP on it, that you acquire the merits to medicate God.
You can't say God, that's not English, which surpass all other merits in merit.
Look at that.
And your glory will be distinct from the others as is heaven from the earth.
Or if only we had received these teachings that our sufferings would serve to medicate
God, how many riches we would acquire, which now we do not have.
So here you've got the souls in purgatory regretting that they didn't have this sublime
teaching and that they could have done such an incredible work for God.
Okay?
So we'll find that fascination, do you, because they see things very clearly.
So the next one is October the 3rd, 1906.
Jesus speaks about simplicity.
We're back to Matthew 18, 1 to 3, the simplicity of a child, okay?
18 verses 1 to 3.
As I was in my usual state, blessed Jesus came for just a little, and he told me, my
daughter, simplicity fills the soul with grace to the point of diffusing outside.
Okay?
That's John 7, 37 to 39, that out of your own heart will flow fountains of living water.
So if one wanted to constrain grace within her, this couldn't be.
In fact, just as the spirit of God, because he is most simple, diffuses everywhere without
effort or strain, but rather naturally, in the same way, the soul who possesses the virtue
of simplicity, diffuses grace in others without even realizing it, is not absolutely fantastic.
So that means that the Lord can use you anywhere, anytime, under any conditions, and you're
not even aware of it, and it's even more powerful when you're not aware of it.
Okay, so I want to give you a few scriptures for that.
Psalm 119 verse 130, Psalm 119 verse 130, Psalm 116 verse 6, and Romans 16, 19.
So the next one is October the 4th, 1906, how upright working, we don't use the word
operating, do we?
Is the breath that lights the fire of love?
In other words, the actions are needed.
Having received the obedience to speak only a few words, if anyone came, do you remember
it?
That's what she asked a little, a few messages back.
I was concerned that I had failed the obedience and added that to that, blessed Jesus was not
coming.
You can say the torment of my soul, thinking that he was not coming because I had committed
sin.
His privation is always a cruel torment, but the thought of having provided the occasion
for it because of some fault is a torment that makes one go mad and kills with one blow.
It's not interesting.
There you're dealing with the real saint.
The idea that you would have offended the Lord would really, really genuine the obsession.
Then after I struggled very much, he came and he touched me three times.
Three is the divine signature, isn't it?
Telling me, my daughter, I renew in you, watch this, the power of the Father, one touch,
in my wisdom, the second one, and in the love of the Holy Spirit, the third one.
What I felt as he was saying this, I am unable to express.
When he seemed to lie down within me, placing his head crowned with thorns upon my heart
and he added, "Opright, we would say righteous working keeps divine love always lit within
the soul while they working, which is not upright or righteous, keeps putting it out.
And if it tries to lighten the breath of love of itself comes and puts it out, the breath
of self-love puts it out, and then human respect puts it out and then self-esteem does it.
And the breath of desire to please others, in some many breaths, always keep putting
it out.
This is the breath of God being put out by this other stuff.
In other words, the Holy Spirit will only stay in a holy sanctuary.
While with the righteous operating or working, it's not many breaths that light this divine
fire in the soul, but one continuous breath which keeps it always lit.
Now, there you've got the firmness, stability, perseverance, and everything again.
You see it, constancy, the one continuous breath, and it's only the omnipotent breath
of God that's Ruach Adhanai, or you A.C.H., or you A.C.H., A-D-O-N-I-A-I, A-D-O-N-A-I.
Ruach Adhanai is the Hebrew for the breath of God, and it's Genesis 2.7.
So notice that the Holy Spirit doesn't stay if the sanctuary isn't right.
So October 5, 1906, Jesus is the master of the soul.
Continuing my usual state, I found myself outside of myself together with baby Jesus.
This time it seemed he felt like playing.
He would press himself against my breast and in my arms, and while looking at me with great
love, he would clasp me, or he would push me and almost knock me, knock against me with
his little head, or he would kiss me so strongly that it seemed he wanted to enclose me and
identify me with himself.
While he would do this, I would feel great pain.
Now notice now pleasure.
So much so as to feel faint.
But even though he would see me suffer like that, he wouldn't pay any attention.
On the contrary, he would see from my face that I was suffering, since I would not dare
tell him anything.
He would do it harder, and he would make me suffer more.
And then after he gave vent to himself very well, I've tried to put that in English.
He told me, "My daughter, I am your master."
He came as a child, okay, this is the conflict you get in images, okay.
And I can do with you whatever I want.
Know that since you are mine, you are no longer the master of yourself.
Now that's the bit that people find difficult in divine will.
We don't mind saying, "I give you my will," as long as you don't take it.
And if he takes it, you say, "It's not mine anymore."
Okay, that's like saying in a rash moment, "I give you this hundred thousand, and you
take it, and I don't have it anymore."
I gave you that example because it would be something you'd feel.
And so what he's doing is giving her an exercise to let her know that giving your will to him
is B.I.G.
It's very big.
And he says, as you go into the higher volumes, that when a person is genuinely permanently
given their will, that there's nothing else for him to ask for, because you've given him
the very essence of your being, okay.
So he says, "You're no longer master of yourself, and if you arbitrate something, even just one
thought, one desire, one heartbeat, know that you are making a theft from me."
It's mine.
So you know you're either married or you're not.
It's what you're being told.
Ephesians 6.9, Ephesians 6.9, and Colossians 4.1.
I would think that that little exercise was not so much for Louisa, but for the people
she's writing to.
It's for us.
All of these messages are more for us than for her, and he tells her that every now and
then that he, because at one stage she actually asked him, "Why do I go through all of this,
you know, having to ask you this and you've got to teach me that and all of it?"
He said, "It's for the people you're writing to."
That's my quick way of saying it, that he said, "Many of these lessons are not for you
at all.
You don't need them."
That one, I would definitely think is for us.
So at that moment I saw the confessor, that's Father Genaro De Genaro, G-E-N-N-A-R-O, and
D-I, and G-E-N-N-A-R-O, Father Genaro De Genaro.
I saw the confessor who not feeling very well wanted as though to unload his sufferings
on to me.
This is the bit about healing I wanted to look at.
He wants to get rid of these sufferings, and he wants healing.
He wanted to unload his sufferings on to me, and all hurriedly he, that's Jesus, pushed
him away with his hand and said, "I have to unload my pains first.
Who's first?
Who's master?"
You see, which are many, and then you can do it.
And while saying this, he drew near my mouth and poured a most bitter liquor into it, then
I commended the confessor to him, praying him to touch him with his little hand, and to
make him get well, he touched him and said, "Yes, yes," and he disappeared.
Why did he say, "Yes, yes," because I've just explained to you that healing the body
isn't.
It's a day.
It's not a big day.
It's not a day.
Surely the priest who's listening, who's the first person listening to all of this teaching
should have known better, but that's all right until you get the flu or a headache.
And then you say, "Where's the paracetamol?"
You know what I mean.
So it's very interesting, the difference between what you know theoretically and what
you know actually practically.
Now, it's a quarter past eight, do you want me to stop there for a discussion?
Up to you?
Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]